die aufkündigung des pariser klima
abkommens durch die usa war ein schlag
ins kontor der ganzen welt in eine
verhöhnung der opfer des klimawandels
aber werden die usa vielleicht gar nicht
gebraucht und es gibt eine andere viel
effektivere lösung durch die das
fehlverhalten amerikas ausgeglichen
werden kann
geoengineering könnte eine lösung sein
noch stecken die technologien in den
kinderschuhen aber jetzt wurde in der
schweiz die erste kommerzielle anlage
weltweit zum recycling von co2 aus der
luft in betrieb genommen ob das die
lösung zur verhinderung der
klimakatastrophe ist jetzt endlich zum
science fiction herbst will kommt es ist
eine ziemlich verlockende technologie
eine anlage die nicht nur co2 aus der
luft filtert sondern das gas dann auch
noch für pflanzen nutzt und damit zwei
probleme auf einmal löst die
verlangsamung des klimawandels und eine
steigerung der nahrungsmittelproduktion
bis heute weil die gewinnung von co2 aus
der umgebungsluft als eigentlich viel zu
teuer
eine ausgerechnet amerikanische studien
bezifferten die kosten 2011 mit 740 euro
pro tonne utopisch hoch so wäre die
lösung von 42 viel zu teuer
jetzt hat aber die schweizer firma klein
birds mit ihrer technologie wohl den
gordischen knoten zerschlagen mit dem
verkauf befehl zwei zu marktpreisen an
ein gewächshaus soll die anlage beweisen
dass die technologie des drk trinkt
rentabel ist dafür wird bei dieser
ersten anderen kein strom zur filterung
benötigt sondern die notwendige energie
wird aus abwärme gewonnen so entfällt
ein erheblicher teil der kosten
zusätzlich ist die filtertechnologie von
kann das effektiv und unkompliziert ein
filter aus porösem granular bindet das
co2 mit hilfe wird in der luft
enthaltenen wassers und chemischen
bindemitteln ist der fischer gesättigt
wird er auf 100 grad erhitzt und wasser
und co2 verdampfen das co2 wird
abgespalten und gesammelt noch ist die
technologie am anfang die anlage besteht
aus 54 filtern und kann die jährlichen
abgabe von 200 pkw aus der luft filtern
für die abgase allein der berliner 13
millionen autos werden
1000 solcher anlagen nötig klein works
kann zurzeit drei anlagen pro jahr
frauen und um nur ein prozent der
globalen co2 emissionen zu zeigen
während eine viertel million solcher
anlagen nötig 15% 25 millionen für 100%
25 millionen solcher anlagen moment da
finde ich jetzt gar nicht mehr utopisch
wir haben mehr als eine milliarde autos
auf der erde
da können wir doch locker mal 25
millionen solcher anlagen aufstellen
sicher wird er sich von jetzt auf gleich
gehen aber utopisch finde ich nicht vor
allem wenn es sich rechnet und damit die
pflanzenproduktion zum beispiel für die
welternährung verbessert werden kann
ich finde das ist mal so ein lichtblick
der wieder echt begeistert wenn sich
etwas neues tut dann habe ich euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn er kein
video verpassen wollt dann tut mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke dann werdet ihr auch über
jedes neue video informiert hier geht es
weiter mit dem wetterchaos das jetzt
durch den klimawandel begonnen hat und
ich sage bist dann bleibt dran
draufklicken wenn sie zu viert gespannt